pressure on white's pieces white just
lacked that one move to bring that rook
in the corner into the game and because
he lacked that one move
white's king is going to be doomed
nakamura really upping the pressure just
the last six moves alone
have turned the tables in his favor and
nakamura leaning back that made me think
has westley resigned but no not yet no
but there's some threats in the air you
know of course there's bishop takes
knight that's the immediate pressing
problem you also have moves like rook
takes rook and the bishop coming out and
pinning the rook and the king lots of
problems there we go it is actually a
result wesley so resigns it was hopeless
but
feels like an early resignation nakamura
super happy on the camera there a two
nil victory in the blitz games all right
well it's over
after a long day for these two wesley so
loses in tie breaks to hikar nakamura
nakamura the winner gaining two points
in this match wesley so one point for
him it was a big chance for wesley so to
really get closer to magnus carlson he's
still getting closer